script was copy written in 2003 so I had
this idea a while ago and the Genesis
pretty much was what would be the most
impossible building to take over in the
world and the White House and then I
thought Mary that to the idea of a
Secret Service agent in his prime hadn't
seen that in a movie I'm in the line of
fire had Clint Eastwood but he was in
the twilight of his career and another
movie that we like to live and die in LA
had Secret Service agents but they were
dealing with counterfeiters but a Secret
Service hero in his prime protecting the
president hadn't seen that and I thought
that would be a great that would be a
great hero to follow and combine that
with the most impossible building to
take over in the world and I thought
that was something that audiences might
be interested in seeing when I
originally started writing uh I had a
corporate job and I would get up every
morning at four clock before I would go
to work right for a couple hours have my
day come home watch movies at night read
scripts go to bed get up at four o'clock
the next morning and I did that for a
number of years until 2002 when I was
fortunate to win the nickel fellowship
and that got me my first agent um it
gave me the confidence and encouragement
that this might be a career and so I
quit my corporate job and from that
moment forward I was pretty much full
speed ahead trying to make it as a
screenwriter we both had you know good
corporate jobs and we owned a home and
you know we're kind of living the whole
you know the i guess the suburban life I
guess you can say and then but it was
always our dream to write it was always
our dream to pursue our passion and so
finally in 2007 we kind of just looked
at each other and say you know if we're
going to do this thing let's just let's
just go to California let's just do it
so we've been writing for a number of
years already we feel like we've honed
our craft we feel like we've had we've
written a lot of spec scripts and we
were just really hoping that someone
would eventually respond to so we sold
her house and everyone thought we were
nuts and one thought we were crazy our
friends and family were like what what
are you doing you know and if anyone
from the east coast you don't sell your
house in the middle winner in the middle
of school year you just don't do that
which is what we did and we were
fortunate enough to to sell our house
right before everything collapsed and so
it was a good time we then had this big
high of you know selling her house and
getting out here and then the writers
strike it so it was like okay so it was
literally one of those entourage
episodes you know
highest of highs and the lowest lows you
know within you know weeks of each other
you know so then we came out here and we
just realized that we just every single
day we treated it like a full-time job
even though we weren't getting any
income so it was working you know 40 40
to 50 hours a week writing every single
day constantly working on new specs
because that's really the lifeblood of
any any writer so we it from 2000 ins
yeah our uh our bank account continuing
to go down now every year our spec
scripts kept going up okay you have
another spec script but another spec
script no money no money no money more
spec scripts you know we had a couple
real close calls that we thought
something was going to sell and then it
didn't for whatever reason and at the
time that can be very frustrating and
you just have to keep persevering and
just keep believing that at some point
it's going to happen and then in 2011 in
autumn of 2011 we got our new reps off
of one of the spec scripts that we had
written over those years and we were
grateful to get them and when we did
they looked at our projects that we had
and they said the first one we want to
go out with his Olympus has fallen and
we were ecstatic because we had always
believed that you know it could make a
great action movie and they rewrote it
for them extensively about four times
they took it out in March of 2012 I
after it sold to millennium and we
rewrote it for the studio and then their
director Antoine Fuqua at another eight
times before it went to the cameras and
after that long wait we actually had our
script sell in March of 2012 in the
movie come out in March of 2013 which is
almost unheard of in Hollywood so in a
long wait and then everything went
really quickly antoine fuqua brought
some great ideas the movie that you see
is much more raw and gritty and edgy
than the script we originally wrote
because that was his vision that's
antoine fuqua he did training day and so
we pulled everything back to make it as
real and plausible as possible he
brought in some Secret Service
consultants that we talked with
extensively while we were writing in
pre-production and they gave us a lot of
insights we actually had guessed
correctly on a lot of things that we
wrote in to the original script when
they when they first met us the Secret
Service guys looked at and said who do
you know and we said nobody
because four or five things that we had
just made up exists one of them that I
can tell you is the we knew from our
research that Truman had built the new
White House over the walls of the old
and so we said well there's gotta be
maybe some spaces in between there to
maneuver around and the Secret Service
agents told us Amy Carter got lost in
them all the time and that they really
do exist so that was one thing that we
had guessed correctly on and there was
about four or five things that we did
but they were even to tell us a lot more
and we incorporated all that into the
rewrites to make this as plausible and
real as we could and it was everything
from he would go to we went to the test
screening and you know we always heard
you know these you know these horror
stories okay you turn in your script you
turn in your rewrites okay goodbye we
don't wanna hear from the writers
anymore but we went to the test
screening initially and it was a really
rough cut screening so there was a lot
of missing pieces in the movie at that
time but you know film district was
there and everybody was doing their
surveys and giving feedback and they
really valued everyone's feedback you
know including ours and it was really
fantastic and to the point where even
following up with marc gill at
millennium afterwards he would reach out
to us and say what you guys think and we
were literally able to go we gave until
notes we done like 15 20 things and he
came back to us on each of those things
yes we like this we can do this yes
we've already done that this one's going
to be a little tough because somebody
like really likes to go this way but he
they were so collaborative and kept us
in the loop so much we were really
appreciative and even comments on
editing I mean we were able to talk to
the editor and say okay you know that
sequence when the trash trucks are
coming in you need to have them drop
indeed we pull boxes here before this
happens and they absolutely took our
input and and you know really
incorporated and it was really a
pleasure well Marc Gill first of all the
president millennium called us last
night we watched the movie down we live
in down at Norwich County in newport
beach and we went with some friends to
watch it down there we got a call from
him right beforehand just telling us
that the numbers were looking much
better than had originally expected and
so the studio was thrilled and then
today he sent an email to the two of us
and our reps and its really nice email
yeah just just in essence saying you
know he's a guy we got it he's really a
guy we got an a- cinemascore you know so
far which there's been the best of a
movie this year he said zero dark thirty
was the only one that got another a
minus and the numbers were tracking even
better than they expected and
he pretty much just said like thank you
and if it weren't for you and your
script we'd have nothing and we're just
deeply grateful which was such a nice
thing to get from the president of
studio when you're a writer